this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
press in code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday may the 25th
the joint is brought to you by
stamps.com one of my [__] favorites
when you're running a small business
listen every second counts so why are
you still taking time out of your day to
go to the post office when you could be
using stamps.com instead make mailing
and shipping quick easy and cost
effective with stamps.com
my wife and i have been with stamps.com
for close to 10 years it is easy peasy
you put it on the scale you measure it
you put the stamp on you put in your
mailbox you raise that little [__]
flag and when papa comes by he picks it
up and takes it stamps.com gives you
access to all the post office and ups
shipping services you need right now
from your computer and
get discounts you can't find anywhere
else
up to 30 of usps rates and over 80
percent
of ups all you need is a regular
computer and a printer no special
supplies no special equipment and you'll
be up and running in minutes sending
packages letters all over the world
wherever the [__] you want to send them
so stop wasting time and start saving
money with stamps.com to mail and ship
sign up with promo code joey for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage on a digital
scale
no long term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and to code joey j-o-e-y it's
that easy stamps.com tremendous the
joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion when it comes to cbd
listen there ain't nobody better than
the lion how do i know it's a full
spectrum cbd and they cover you from
every dynamic kinesiology tape gummies
they got hemp reefer they got cream they
got
kinesiology tape they got bath balls
listen my cat is still [__] alive
because of cbd lion's animal cbd so get
your [__] together [__]
go to
cbdlion.com
read and understand and listen and learn
cbd can help you on a daily and cbd.com
cbd lions got the answer for you so do
me a favor go to cbd lion
press and code joey start with some
tincture maybe some gummy bears the
delta nines are the [__] kill for and
when you get them now you get a 20
discount it's gonna be a lot cheaper
than you get them at your local health
food store so cbdlion.com
press and code joey let's get this party
started mike it's [__] wednesday jack
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's a wednesday
i think it's the 25th i have no [__]
idea anymore i'm losing the time of this
track of time lately so but it's a
beautiful day to be alive
thank you very much for enjoying the
chaz podcast it was [__] great having
him come to your house with his son
dante mike me it was [__] great he's
uh
it was really awesome guys it was a
great experience uh
i've been speaking to him for a while
and we finally put it together i'm gonna
go on his podcast in uh
june he starts back up we're gonna do
like two episodes so
that's where we're at you know it's
great to have somebody like that that
you could you know learn from for a
little while that guy seen it all that
guy struggled that guy you know
it's funny somebody reminded me of one
of his early movies and now i gotta
[__] watch it because of one of my
favorite movies the last [__]
dragon
with uh
do you like that too i i love that movie
bruce lye bruce lee bruce leroy
bruce leroy and the show gonna harlem
and [__] that's a great [__] movie i
gotta see it again i saw that in the
movie that's how old uncle joey
oh [__]
[__] vanities in it uh with a
non-acting ass
vanity mike clark uh mike starr
[__] a lot of people in that goddamn
movie in fact i saw that kid
my first night in la i walked into
[__] the comedy store
and i saw him talking to eddie griffin
the star in that movie bruce leroy i
almost [__] died
i almost [__] died
but anyway with all that aside today we
have a guest ricky williams i don't know
if you remember him from uh the miami
dolphins great guy we had to do a zoom
he's in la i'm in jersey but it was
pretty interesting got me thinking
because
i didn't take care of myself
until like as a human being like i
didn't know what was listening we don't
know what the [__] going on
you know you eat you you go to the gym
you [__] sleep
and every week somebody talks to you
about carbs this
i i didn't know what was going on but
i didn't start taking care of myself
mentally until i was like 31 years old
when i started i don't know when i got
out of [__] jail
i had some doubts about myself and
whatnot uh those two years that i had
from like 89
to 91 looking back in those years i
[__] struggle a lot i mean once i got
on stage
that took half the [__]
you know like when you want to do
something you don't do it with comedy i
wanted to do it so bad but i didn't have
the balls to do it
so by the time i got to do it it was
such a weight off my [__] shoulders
and i saw all this
[__] that i was going through was coming
from because i would not go on stage for
some reason or another
and if i sit down
and really
talk to you guys about what made me go
on stage it was clarity
because i wasn't clear like i wasn't uh
i wanted to be a stand-up i didn't have
my i didn't have my goals situated i
wanted to be a stand-up comic that was
it i didn't have what level what degree
i didn't know what i wanted to get into
but the defining moment for me
was when i was lost i was lost as a
human being man
and i
i don't know after prison after i got
married and separated that separation
in uh 91 really it just [__] up my
head guys it just made me look in for
the first time ever
and i'd seen the things i'd done i
remember the kidnapping and all that
[__] and i figured you know this is
maybe a religious matter
so i looked in my religious [__] uh
life and i said oh [__]
when i got into that altercation with
sister heisent
in the fifth grade i got thrown out and
i never made my confirmation and my
confirmation is basically the holy
spirit for you non-catholics and
whatever the [__] you are yes i'm a
catholic geek so
what did i do at the age of [__] 31
after i made my [__] i got on stage i
went for my confirmation
i did it before i went on stage yeah i
did it before i went on stage i went for
my confirmation
and that entered the spirit of me but
guess what i didn't feel dick
if he entered me he had a little dick i
didn't feel nothing i didn't feel
nothing
i was still a little bit less lost
and
my brother my friend a dear friend of
mine that took care of me his name was
martinelli that was the last name he
was working at a kitchen at naropa
institute in boulder and i went over to
[__] with him one day they got a
[__] free meal because i was a comic
and i was broke he would tell me come
back get a free lunch and you know it
was a vegan place but i still wanted to
eat seven grain bread and you know all
that [__] cause it's free you gotta eat
what the [__] is free you know
so uh
i looked at one of the catalogs from the
school while i was sitting at in the
whatever
in his restaurant at a table and they
had some pretty interesting courses man
and i went to see a speaker there that
was my first experience there
i went to see a speaker uh i forget what
the guy's name is if i showed you his
picture you know i
he's like a [__] well-known i went to
see two guys there but this was the
first one
and it was kind of hippie-ish
i didn't think i belonged there but
the dude was speaking my type of [__] he
was talking about spirituality and
how you have to connect and all this
[__] and i was lost man i was like i
don't know what the [__] this dude was
talking about i smoke reefer i don't
know what the [__] he's talking about
it's like [__]
i signed up for a walking meditation
class and
they taught me how to breathe it was
monday nights i'll never forget this now
i would go there you gotta take your
shoes at the door
you gotta like [__] do something
around the thing and then
you would have to have a thought and
walk around i never forgot this stuff
guys i thought it was so interesting to
me
and i did it for a couple weeks and it
got me by and you know what it got me
over the hump and then i
i didn't look back into that ever again
like i just go i'm cooking with gas now
i don't really have to take care of
myself yeah we all do this [__] you know
oh if once i hit 200 pounds you know and
then we hit 200 and we don't go back to
the gym once you get your blue belt you
don't go back to jiu jitsu you know
there's so many [__] things that
so
from 90 [__] 192
to
95 it was to get my head back
you know it was the first time ever i
felt kind of weird in the mornings and
what i was going through last year when
i moved here was this i kept telling
people it feels like when i got divorced
i was lost i didn't have an anchor
and man when you don't have an anchor
and you're [__] lost and you just get
up and like i had at that time yeah i
was [__] into you know writing stuff
down like my schedule and i was doing
everything i could to take care of
myself that way
but the mind
was where and i always had a reefer
but the problem with the reefer was that
i was doing cocaine and that the reefer
can't nothing works when you're doing
cocaine nothing works
but that's what i got into and then when
i got into comedy i said to myself you
know what i can't even think about the
spiritual world anymore because i'm
going broke
i'm going broke i gotta get on the road
i gotta do [__] so then you go on the
road night and i committed to cocaine i
said [__] it i'm not gonna go with this
[__] feeling
wounded i'm just gonna do cocaine or
whatever and i never even
looked at myself again until i was 44
years old
and that's when you know i had to go to
weight watchers i had a you know and i
never i never really spoke to anybody
but that's when i realized all the
things
that go
together for you to do your job the
right way
you know last year i wasn't doing my job
and i'm still not doing my job the right
way because i'm not a hundred percent
yet
but i'm getting every day and i do the
same [__] every day to take care of
myself my mind i don't put no pressure
on myself
i journal i do a lot of [__] things
but the reefer helps you know the when i
was in l.a what i was doing on the
church was not the way you smoke reefer
guys we were going we were savages on
that church and everybody around us was
savages it's just the way it was that's
not the proper way to smoke reefer you
know and i found that out when i got
here when i had to chase the [__]
dragon all day
and now i smoke before i go to the gym
maybe before mike comes and then at
night is when i need it i go on the
front of my house and i smoke my little
[__] joint i look at the trees and
the mountains and i hear the deer
running around and that's my peace of
mind right there you need peace of mind
every day
and something you know the pandemic was
the best thing that happened because
some people got to look at their lives
for the first time but again after the
pandemic blew over and they switched
jobs and whatever they stopped looking
after you your life you gotta look after
your life it's an everyday check-in
it's an everyday checking with yourself
you know when you when you get older
you're like [__] my ankle hurts my ear
hurts last week i had 15 pains if you
come to me in the morning and go joey
what do you feel uh you know my my knee
hurts my ankle you know all that [__]
but so is the insides of you
show your insides they're rough you got
to take care of them i'm very happy that
i signed up with better help and spoke
to them about therapy and i would never
do this before but now
ever since all this [__] last year i
tell you what man i check up on myself
more than ever i'm very happy i walked
away from comedy for a while to get my
life in my head together
and to just see
what the [__] had happened i needed to
see what the bro when you're in it
you're in it you think when these guys i
read about these musical tours guns and
roses did like a [__] eight-year tour
you know when you do that you ever see
the motley crew movie when he describes
touring
can you imagine doing that and i'm
exaggerating with guns and roses eight
years but all those guys motley went on
a huge two-year [__] you know all
these bands went on these huge when you
come back from that you're a different
person guys you've forgotten everything
you're a different person you just been
in a fantasy for two [__] years on a
bus
jet planes going to london hanging out
with lemmy ozzy you don't even know
what's what you don't even know the [__]
you are
and that's why when i got back i was
like you know what man i'm not feeling
it
i'm going to take a breath and i'll tell
you what i'm not 150
but i'm a lot better than what i was and
i'm consistent with it and i'm happy for
right now it's working so if it ain't
broken don't fix it [__] listen
it was a pleasure to have this guy on
the show we had a great [__] talk
uh enjoy [__] ricky
williams joy
[Music]
what's happening little brother
what's going on welcome to uncle joey's
joint what's happening mr williams
i'm just hanging out you looking good
what's going on in your world
what's going on a lot a lot of stuff a
lot of hustling
you teach yoga today
i did not teach you i did a little bit
of yoga but i did a little
yeah i'm taking your lead you know what
i'm saying yeah great to have you on big
fan big uh believer in what you're doing
now
uh
wanted to talk to you for years now
yeah one of my guys that you know
i'm falling into your web
slowly but slowly i've been an
acupuncture for
15 years wow you know because yeah i was
418 and i wanted circulation and i
used it for a cocaine addiction you know
and it really worked i mean no rehab no
hugs
no crying none of that [__] she just
stuck me with needles and
she would put a uh an earring on me
every week like an acupuncture thing
because that's an addiction thing yeah
and i would [__] pop it i would leave
there and go do coke i did that for
about a year and i got sick and tired of
popping the earring and i said [__] it
dr amy you got me so i moved to jersey
now and i got a great acupuncturist a
japanese italian lady oh wow the
japanese are very precise you know
they're very good at what they do so
yeah it's wonderful i mean it's just not
that whole way of looking at the body
and understanding health is to me it
saved my life saved my life too well
i got one foot in the grave want a
banana peel but i'm pushing every day mr
williams amen today and uh we also have
another thing in common which i'm very
happy you went public with
and that was social anxiety i'm a
stand-up comic ricky yeah you know i go
out i do shows you talk to people
afterward in the last
four years like from 216 to
21 to the pandemic i was starting to get
social anxiety yeah when there'll be too
many people and i've been doing this all
my life you know cracking jokes i always
have a thousand people around you
cracking jokes but
this was something different it was
painful
yeah it was starting to get painful i i
didn't
my the people who came to the shows
probably thought that i just didn't want
to talk to him yeah i couldn't do it
anymore yeah i couldn't hold the focus
how did you find out you had it how did
you find out yeah find out you had it
well i mean the whole i think the whole
thing of anxiety is is you feel it you
know something that felt comfortable you
notice you know something doesn't feel
right here and you know as a football
player as a guy i just tried to push
through it and say like
i just got to push through it
but i got to the point where i realized
you know maybe this is trying to tell me
something
you know and i think
at least for me as a kid i was always
looking outside to see what i had to do
or what i had to be to to get acceptance
from other people and i worked all the
way up to being a professional athlete
and then i started to realize i actually
needed to accept and love myself and i
realized chasing other people's approval
put me in a place where i didn't even
know who i was and so i needed to take
some time off and
and be by myself and get to know get to
know myself and as soon as i did that
the anxiety you know 95 of it
disappeared because i knew who i was and
i started making choices based on what
felt good to me not what i had to force
myself to do in order to get other
people's approval
you know that's a beautiful thing
because that's how i feel
a lot
yeah you know right now i'm dealing with
the stand-up comedy thing
and i want to go back to it but i want
to go back to it on my terms yeah you
know that's what happened that's what
happened with me that's exactly what
happened with me yeah but i'm going to
tell you something even at my terms
i don't think it's going to stick around
long i just don't uh i don't know
sometimes you
i did it my wife we had a child when i
was 50 and that really
turned you know i wanted to find myself
you know when you see your child
as your child is growing you learn a lot
from you about yourself from that child
yeah at least i did i would look at that
and then i would compare myself like men
at eight eight years old i was running
numbers for a bookmaker my daughter
doesn't have a [__] clue yeah you
know she has no resume whatever but
and that helped but i think that i
wanted once i got to see my child and i
started finding little things out about
myself i want to explore those things
too and see what's going on
and last week i was outside i was i had
a comedy show thursday night and i was
outside with a bunch of kids and moms
and just talking [__] you know and the
kids are running around awesome i got to
get in my car to go do comedy
that was terrible
yeah like i felt awful you
know sometimes i think we do you know
it's like going to college it's like
picking a major when you're 18.
you don't know [__] about [__] life
when you're 18.
but your parents was an attorney yeah
i'm gonna go to the and after two years
you're like this ain't me i just want to
sell fruit
yeah i just want to sell apples and sell
flowers on the [__] corner yeah and
that's but you get put into that
pressure and then the marriage
you know the college sweetheart and also
in the other college kid
and it's just you have to some like for
me
last thing i remember ricky was 1993.
uh you know what i know exactly what you
mean because i was there and that's when
i woke up and i said you know there's
got to be there's got to be a different
way to live my life
and so i just started i just really i
just said [__] it i'm going to do me and
see what happens if it doesn't work i'll
go back to pretended but i said i want
to at least try being myself and see how
it goes
and it just became addictive i started
to enjoy everything even the stuff that
i used to hate i started to enjoy
because it was about the experience of
what i could learn about myself
it wasn't about you know
checking some box or doing something
again to get other people's approval
it's a beautiful thing man and then how
do you tie in
because i bought listen
i was a [__] geek
mr williams growing up i was a karate
dude i bowed i thought bruce lee was
[__] god you know
and then like i was a catholic
i saw people getting high and i didn't
like it when i was a kid but i knew
there was nothing wrong with reefer even
as a kid i'm like that just makes them
giggle yeah and i'd see my godfather do
it and my mother do it but i wasn't
allowed to talk on the street what i saw
in my house yeah if you came up to me
you were like you know i'm thinking of
smoking pot i'd say [__] do it yeah
because it don't it just makes you
giggle i look at my godfather he just
sits on the couch and giggles like a
[__] idiot you know it doesn't really
affect them like how come my mother had
a bar
i don't drink yeah i saw the effects of
alcohol you ever been around somebody
who's drinking i can't handle it i can't
handle i can't do it either that's where
my social goes right the [__] up i don't
understand it you know when i go to a
bar i get anxiety why because i don't
[__] drink yeah i want to smoke 10
joints and i i can't sit at the bar and
talk to it's it's just a class so yeah
i think that's what really like when i
got back when i moved here after you
know i moved here in august to 2020 i
was like wow i don't even know what the
[__] i am
i moved back to new jersey where it all
started
and i didn't know
who i was anymore
people coming up to me saying they want
to take a picture of me why i want the
[__] prison
there's a doctor out there that saved a
little [__] kid nobody wants to take
a picture of that [__] dude
so i didn't understand all these things
and all of them gave me anxiety
like it just
and now i switch medications i had a bad
bout with xanax i switch medications i
go to a doctor
and uh it's under control man yeah the
gym acupuncture a little reefer not too
see the edibles were killing me i think
the edibles
i'm i'm dropping 1500 milligrams and
that devil says gracious yeah i got a
big tolerance you know so
it's just uh i think that added to the
anxiety that's a little bit of fuel
yeah for sure
you know it's a process to me like you
know when i when i started really
dealing with my social anxiety i
realized it was two things it was one it
was it was changing my internal habits
of thinking
you know it was because that's the main
thing when people say mental health to
me what mental means is they're talking
about what's on the inside right and i
think at least for me the time i was
born i wasn't really worried so much
about what was on the inside i was so
worried about what i had to do
externally and so when i fir i finally
started to turn inside and this is what
cannabis really helped me do
you know that's what happens when we
smoke it makes us more aware of what's
going on on the inside and for a lot of
people if we haven't really been paying
attention it's a lot you know it's that
feeling when you haven't cleaned
something for a long time you kept the
garage you keep putting it off and then
finally that one day you say okay i'm
gonna go attack the garage and then you
step in and you're like whoa it's a lot
okay
i think that's when people get paranoid
or they get anxious when they smoke is
because it's too much right and what i
realize is that the aim is you have to
love and know who you are on the inside
but there's a lot of stuff we've been
we've been piling in there and so go
slow is what i tell people and having
someone it doesn't have to be a
therapist
but just having someone you trust who
you can really talk to because once you
get become more aware of the stuff on
the inside it can't just stay there it
actually has to move and so having
someone again doesn't have to be a
therapist but having someone you trust
who you can actually talk to who's not
going to judge you that's the process is
get in touch with what's going on on the
inside and find someone you can talk to
about it and then it starts to move and
you start to see it and then it's not so
scary because it's buried it's out in
the front so you can actually do
something with it
and did you i i speak to a therapist
still once a week just to you know keep
everything balanced i got my wife i
could tell her whatever the [__] i want
she's cool with me like that so
but this is life though this is life to
me this is like we we pretend and we've
been taught it's not but this is life
and if we if you have like a wife that
you can tell anyone if you have any
person in your life that you can talk to
about anything to me that's the most
important medicine
most important medicine you can have in
life it's just at least one person that
has your back that you can tell them
anything and they're gonna they're gonna
love you through it to me
as soon as i had that half of my anxiety
disappeared you know because i think as
as we're we're social beings and we need
connection but even uh we have a lot of
friends that's the superficial
connection you know as social beings we
need a deep connection with someone and
a deep connection means someone who's
seen your ass you know someone who's
seen all of you and they still love you
when you have that like i think you can
take on anything in the world my wife
smelled my feet she loves me dog yeah
yeah it's real i think it's this fungi
toenail cheesy [__] that's not good so
if she stuck around for 22 years i could
tell anything yeah you're doing
something right you're doing something
right no i i dig what you're saying and
i dig you know when
you first retired you know i was
listening to you and i remember having
conversations with broken about you on
planes we would just talk about you and
i'm like you know
i go you know what probably happened man
sometimes i think marijuana helps you
you know the great bill hicks had a joke
and i know i love this joke he said
marijuana don't make you lazy
it just makes you realize that what
you're gonna do
ain't worth getting up amen to that
[__] joke
that's it that's it and it says
sometimes you smoke a joint you're like
whenever i got a problem
you know before i started talking to
therapy i would just smoke a joint go
for a walk that's the answer for me
that's what worked a little walk i need
material i smoke a little bit go for a
walk
it's been working for thousands of years
thousands of years that's you know if we
look at our history we were hunters and
gatherers we were nomads and so when we
got to a place and all of the food and
all the water and everything dried up we
we smoked one and we started walking
right and we found a new place to settle
and build it's ancient it's ancient
medicine it's real
you like that it's legalized now i know
you were always after going after it
that was one of your main things like
cypress hill
well i think the main thing is you look
at all the people not only the people
that are still in prison but the people
that have served time the people who
ruined their life who lost their jobs
all of the people that have been
punished because of this plan has been
illegal that that's my that's my biggest
gripe is people are i mean we
we say in the in the constitution or the
declaration of independence life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness like if
that's not what cannabis is about then i
mean what are we doing so to me to be
americans and to say people can't
consume a plant to help that helps them
feel better that's ridiculous it's crazy
it's un-american
i also feel a lot better since i've been
uh doing cbd every day yeah yeah i uh
i'm sponsored by a great company and
they sent me a full spectrum and you
know i do two times a day i hit that
and my life's been a little bit more
slower yeah it's a little bit more
tranquil you know you're feeling i hate
saying those words people like joy what
are you talking about yeah it's a little
bit more tranquil
at night you know i had to learn to
reissue my sleep again
and i think that helped me out also you
know i gave up you know my tolerance is
so high i got to smoke like 35 percent
weed to get eyes but now i got a system
i just smoke in the morning
and i smoke at night and i'm good when i
would
yeah and this is after like i said i've
been smoking since i was 13 and i hit it
for two or three years i was ashamed to
smoke mr williams i'll tell you why
because i was a catholic
but whatever i was feeling
that [__] i had at that age because in
the 70s nobody spoke about anxiety
it disappeared whenever i smoked pot
and after my mother died i really dove
into marijuana that was my savior to
keep my head in chill
and then i just came to terms that this
is something i'm gonna do the rest of my
life
yeah
this is something that i know it keeps
my powder dry yeah like that dude treat
william said in something
some
some [__] movie i was watching he
kept saying it keeps my powder dry yeah
that's important
you know it is very important yeah life
is short and if we you know our powders
wet too much you know we waste time
waste time well it takes you under and
it doesn't let you grow and see life for
what it is when you have it's like
acupuncture you have a blockage
you have a [__] blockage
in one of your uh
you know the center floridians
you're gonna open up that blockage yeah
and we have blockages all over our body
when we wake up in the morning and
throughout the day we have different
things but still we have our breathing
our yoga
you know walking on the grass with no
feet on to connect to the earth we have
so many things like my pool opens up
uh this weekend you know and i'm so
excited because i could walk on the
grass barefoot
so so how does it feel how does it feel
when you're around your like old friends
and you start talking like this like
do they look at you like you're crazy do
you not talk about this stuff or like
how do you how do you deal with that
whatever my friends call me the jersey
ones the [__] you know the
knuckleheads that i love until the end
of time yeah because california you know
i went to colorado first i was a
[__] boulder
for 12 years okay
yes you learned a lot in bold i went to
naropa institute you know you talk to
those guys i learned how to meditate i
was always looking for an answer
i've always been looking
for what makes you feel good
spiritually and mentally i'm a cuban
dude so i got santeria yeah the santeria
is the spiritual life
the people who look over you you know
the people that you pray for that you
light a candle for on mondays
that they're your people who watch you
so i always understood all these things
about life i went to boulder i learned a
lot there and then you go to cali and
you talk to people who are smarter than
you and they really open your eyes to a
lot of things that make sense
i'm so rooted in catholicism and my
santeria roots from cuba
but i at heart i'm a buddhist
i really believe the whole thing you
know i read a lot of uh the readings i
mean
i don't even know where i put the book
after the move but i really always have
thought of that buddhist lifestyle you
know karma what you put in you get out
you know all those things they've always
made sense to me
so i've always been in search of
and
you know at about i'm
10 months from being 60 and i'll tell
you what has always worked to me
if i got to say what has worked for me
it has been my marijuana use
it kept my powder dry all those years
you know and then when i got locked up i
couldn't smoke for those 18 months or
whatever
and i consider that a a big help at that
time i needed to when i got locked up i
needed to absorb what the [__] was
really happening
if not i would be back out there doing
the same [__] i was doing ricky williams
wow i hear you so you have to you know
you have to clean everything out and
[__] absorb what's really happening
i'm getting punished
for something i [__] did this isn't a
[__] joke
this isn't a [__] joke anymore okay i
i got people at home waiting for me i
got people i disappointed
it's [__] time but then i got out of
jail and i started doing the same [__]
again
and then i realized i hadn't made my
confirmation in 91 right before i got
into comedy and that's when i went to
the naropa institute
and i joined up and
two months later i got into comedy and
that's where
a sort of a piece came
there was a piece but there was still
skeletons that had to be taken care of
so since that time to now
you know i tell people all the time you
got to check on your skeletons from time
to time because when those [__]
come out and check on you it's not good
so it's too late it's too late if
they're checking on you it's too late
yeah
yeah so you have a medical marijuana
company now
i do i have a medical marijuana and i
have a recreational marijuana company so
my medical marijuana company is called
real wellness and it's really uh when i
started consuming cannabis i started
learning about other herbs and realized
you know that herbs are a much more
humane safer way to go to take care of
our body than pharmaceuticals
and then my recreational cannabis
company is called heisman
h-i-g-h-s-m-a-n
and it's not about a trophy it's about
having these kinds of conversations and
talking about
how getting high or consuming cannabis
actually helps us find true happiness
and achieve our goals meaningful goals
because for me i was chasing external
goals and i reached them but they
weren't meaningful i started consuming
cannabis getting more in touch with my
internal goals and as i've pursued and
reached those it's been much more
fulfilling
and
it's funny you asked me for what happens
when i talk to my friends about this
whenever my friends call me and then a
pinch i refer
you know acupuncture
i refer maybe a little refr maybe a
little writing you know i think that
they look at me and they think i'm
[__] crazy i'm a big journaler you
know you don't have something on paper
you really can't see what your situation
is how many nights have i gone upstairs
and gone to sleep and this one [__]
hang in the nail
will not let you fall asleep and then
you toss and turn all night when that
[__] happens to me
all bets are off i come downstairs i
open the notebook let's talk about what
the [__] is bothering me
mr williams came over and took two
joints instead of one you know what am i
gonna do about this do i have to call
his mother and tell him come on ricky he
took two joints instead of one
those little and that that's me but
that's who i am i get hung up on
those little things you know when you
smoke pot it makes you look within
so when i go to an audition
you start looking within
it's dangerous because you're going to
get the truth yeah when you do stand up
and you tape it
your performance and you take it back to
your room and you do a little reefer and
then you listen to it because i don't
want to watch me but i'll listen to like
pivotal jokes just to see if i'm saying
them right jesus christ it makes it
cleans house for me reefer has been a
a spiritual confession
that's how i call my consumption
of reefer you know there's recreational
reefer for me
and then there's the reefer from my mind
i smoke it i take a walk around the park
i sit down on the bench i breathe a
little bit
you know i focus on my third eye
you know just little things like that
this is beautiful man this is this is
beautiful two men having this
conversation and i hope that helps
people listen i hope people listening
are getting curious about what the hell
we're talking about
you know because it's real i mean these
these little moments of when we can like
reclaim a sense of peace and like
balance ourselves like everything lines
up see i don't think i think
enlightenment i think we've all
experienced glimpses of enlightenment
you know and i think when they talk
about the buddha becoming enlightened he
was just able to hold it more
consistently but we all have had those
glimpses where everything just feels
like you know those times you look in
the mirror and you're like damn
you know everything's going well that's
enlightenment it's just how can we how
can we keep it going how can we make it
more consistent
now where is your marijuana company
located california obviously we're we're
based in california but we're also in
oregon and uh we're in conversations
right now with you know several other
states so we're you know it's our
it's our intention to become a a
national brand and really get this
conversation this type of conversation
going going on you know not even only
throughout the country but really
throughout the world because
like you said
it's like reefer you know it's medicine
and i think
people used to talk about medicinal
marijuana and still people would laugh
but when we're when you see two people
who actually are using it this way and
sharing their experiences you know and
obviously people are interested enough
in us to be listening to this so i you
know i think this is wonderful
i think this is wonderful i like to
offer you whenever you want to come on
you're always welcome if you want to
promote anything
talk about anything any new
enlightenments that you have
yeah
that'd be great let me ask you a couple
questions i'll get you out of here yeah
is there any part of you that misses
football
at any level
there's not a part of me that misses
football but there is something i miss
about football and the thing i miss
about football is when you show up for
work there's no excuses you know
everyone like the
the coach tells you what your job is and
then you go out there and execute and
then after work after practice you go
back in and you watch the film and you
see how am i doing so just this attitude
of excellence that there's no excuses we
just work towards excellence on a daily
basis i miss that i miss that i mean i
have it within myself i push myself that
way but you know in the football world
that that's what everyone is there for
but i find in the regular world is
almost the opposite where people are
always making excuses and pretending you
know that they're not responsible for
what's going on in their life and so you
know you talked about the law of karma
the law of karma that's what i loved
about football it was real like the film
doesn't lie you know
the film loves it did you do your job
right you can see it right there and if
you didn't right you have help to help
you get better and i just love that idea
because to me that's life is is the
linebackers you know the the bills the
issues the people they don't stop right
but your ability to meet all of them and
do your job and handle them with dignity
and respect you keep growing and you
keep learning and life becomes worth it
you know it becomes worth it you know
you were always a beautiful man and you
become a more beautiful of a man and the
reason i asked you
if you have any
inclination about football ever
football's changing
football's changing across you know
everywhere i mean it's you
they play in england whatever but it's
changing the united states you know when
i was growing up there were
i don't know eight
football teams for the town of north
bergen now there's like four
you know moms are not putting their
children in and even though we're
getting extra helmets we're getting
better padding
the nfl's doing technology whatever
i think that you would be
a [__] tremendous coach to the youth
yeah i think that you would build a
different type of football player one
would be more complete and one that
would be
in charge and in connection with his
body
you know like if you got him at eight
and nine and coach them until 13 14 then
let them out into the world
the lesson you would give them because
you you know you didn't read a [__]
book you would end the trenches you you
know
one of the best you were there
but i'm sure that you could have been
better of your mind
100 100 i would love to see if i had an
eight-year-old son
even if my wife said no [__] you he's
going to ricky williams before whatever
coach him for two years until he gets to
12 because he's going to be a different
man going into football you have
enlightened yourself
yeah to a [__] degree that is
beautiful and it's not phony it's not a
wokeness like everybody's well no
it comes from your heart i could feel it
i i see it when your interviews you know
so i think that you have a lot to offer
young men man and
i don't know how you felt about football
but
you got the ability to change
i'm on the same page with you i i mean
the way it was
didn't work out for me but i learned so
much and it helped me become who i am so
i feel like i do have a responsibility
to give something back and football is
changing and i've always thought because
football trained me to be the man that i
am today and i think it's a it's a it's
a mistake to say that
that football is is is not a positive
thing because it teaches teamwork it
teaches toughness it teaches how to take
care of your body it teaches how to take
care of the person next to you
um and i think if we cherish these
values as using football to train young
men to be leaders
not millionaires you know i think that
i think that's going to be more useful
that's what happened and that's what
happened to change the game a lot with
college and stuff there's not you know i
watch
i'm a cuban kid i never spoke english so
when i came to the united states
i watched everything i could and i
watched football and
it's changed you know i see and playing
on the street and stuff like that but uh
i think we can make way better football
players i think football got away from
itself i mean i was at the gym before
and i'm watching a football player beat
up a next football player beat up a guy
at newark airport did you see that yeah
i did clock the head the guy went over
but it's funny that you know when you
play football you're built to be rough
and tough
i think in life there's places to be
rough and tough there's places to be
gentle
there's places to be gentle and rough
and tough together amen that's the new
men that are coming up you know that's
that's what's coming up you know so
if you ever coach man i'd be your number
one [__] advocate even if you just
did ricky williams football summer camp
i'll be there to coach with you i love
camps i love five-star basketball camp i
went to booze i went to joe namath's
football camp
i didn't even end up playing football i
went to offense defense football camp in
pittsburgh i saw jack lambert shaving
and dipping his [__] razor in the
toilet water as he was [__] you know
you can't tell that we got a [__] now
jack lambert's mentality nobody could
get true to a guy like that you know
like if you sweat the jackets and listen
i think you should add buddhist and
reefer to your life that [__]
would take his teeth out no those were
solid dudes you know
yes yes the world is changing yes the
world is changing ricky williams you're
a [__] master and i love for what you
did and listen you said something before
that
triggered me a little bit you said that
whatever happened with football no man
that was what you need that's what
needed to happen for you to get to where
you are right now amen the clarity you
didn't fail you didn't do nothing it was
just who you were then
yeah this is who the [__] you
are now you can't put football down
because it's a party when i look at you
i see
the man i see you running at me and me
just [__] fainting you know yeah
because
it's probably gonna hurt yeah well this
was great this was great it was good
good connecting with you and and really
having like a like a heart-to-heart with
another man thank you thank you no i
didn't want this to be i didn't think it
was either gonna be reefer or whatever
but i always had a bone to pick with you
because you opened my eyes about the
social anxiety i didn't know what was
going on i looked it up
and i read the article this is two years
ago i read the article about uh the
helmet yeah like taking that off to make
eye contact and stuff and that's when
you discovered it and blah blah my heart
goes out to you and your family you're a
[__] gentleman and a half
when i come to california i'm coming to
visit in your office and shake your hand
and give you a hug and maybe we'll do a
bong hit for jesus together let's do it
let's do it man how strong is your
reefer over there that high smith it's
strong when they where we're above 30
all all three straights oh [__] so we're
seeing the devil
exactly tom landry and [__]
and i'm saying who else we gotta
come up on this he's got a lot of
knowledge for young players i tried to
talk to him on the phone he was still a
little hollywood henderson yeah ah yeah
i know hollywood we connected when i was
in austin yeah he did uh he hit the
lottery twice or something i know it's
crazy bad [__] i still i have
his book
i still got his book and i still have
the original playboy interview from 1980
i remember the best interview i have
ever read in my life man so
hey it was always a pleasure thank you
god bless you and your family and i love
you man what's the name of the
recreational spot heisman heisman i love
you brother stay black and beautiful i
sure will
all right joey yeah stay black
all right i want to thank you
[__] for supporting this week
we had a great week
uh jazz myself [__] ricky mike we're
all here man it's memorial day on monday
we will be doing a show we'll see you
guys monday morning
have a great [__] weekend you know
be careful
don't drink and drive
and that's it [__] smoke and drive
but use like visine and a lot of [__]
tic tacs that's all i got for you
laughing gas forever it's there
stop in tomorrow thursday tell them
uncle joey sench at the ice cream shop
pick up some [__] uh edibles pick up
some [__] laughing gas
i don't know it's [__] memorial day
weekend stay black and now for a word
for my [__] sponsors jack
all right i want to thank ricky williams
and most importantly i want to thank you
guys for having my back this week we're
trying [__] we're trying to put
something together
so keep coming by and visiting before we
go
the joint is brought to you by
stamps.com
when you're running a small business
every second and every dollar counts
why are you spending your day in the
post office standing online smelling
weird people well you could be when you
can have stamps.com instead make mailing
and shipping quick easy and cost
effective with stamps.com like i told
you in the beginning i love stamps.com
it's easy we get everything out and all
you need is a regular computer and a
printer bing bang boom no special
supplies or equipment you'll be up and
running in minutes printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send jack stop
wasting time and start saving money when
you use stamps.com i don't care if you
got a small business a little business
you're shining shoes and you want to
send postcards stamps.com is the way to
go
sign up with code joey for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
free postage and the digital scale no
longer no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
page and enter code joey the joint is
also brought to you by cbd lion when it
comes to cbd
you don't see me [__] switching
governments i've been with them for like
three or four years it's [__]
tremendous they got me covered from a to
z cream
the hemp smoke the kinesiology tape the
bath balls i mean it never ends with
them cbd gummies that are [__]
tremendous and delta nines
that'll make you hear chinese music the
same way i [__] heard it one night
all right go to cbdline.com press and ko
joey joint church and get 20 off your
first order
that's it and that's that i love you
[__] with all my heart i want
to thank stamps.com
the [__] freeze pipe
manscape
liquid liquidity all you [__]
for being here this week stay black
have a great week and a great memorial
weekend and i'll see you monday morning
tip top magoo you [__] savages love
you